مدد مجلس الامن الدولي ولايه بيعطي حفظ
السلام في لبنان يونيفال لمده عام من دون
الاستجابه لطلب النجاري بضروره تقيد تلك
القوات بمرافقه الجيش اللبناني والتنسيق
معه وكان القرار الذي اجيز بتاييد 13 عضوا
وامتنعت روسيا والصين عن التصويت عليه قد
واجه صعوبات اجلت اختراعا كان مقررا بشانه
يوم الاربعاء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما هي خلفيات قرار مجلس
الامن بتمديد مهمه اليونيفال من دون
الاستجابه لطالب لبنان بضروره ان يواكب
جيشه تحركات تلك القوات وان تنسق معه قبل
تنفيذها وما هي خيارات بيروت للتعامل مع
الواقع الذي يفرضه تمديد مهمه اليونيفال
بصيغته الحاليه وما مدى خطوره تجاهل
التحذيرات اللبنانيه من مغبه السماح
لليونيفال بالتحرك منفرده وما التاثيرات
التي يمكن ان تترتب على هذا القرار في ضوء
التوتر على الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل في
ظل هيمنه الخلاف بين الولايات المتحده
وايران على المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد خلافات اجلت جلسه جلسه كانت مقرره
يوم الاربعاء لتصويت عليه اصدر اذا مجلس
الامن الدولي قرارا بتمديد مهمه بعثه
اليونيفال في لبنان عاما واحدا لم ياخذ في
الاعتبار طلب بيروت بضروره تنسيق تحركات
قوات تلك البعثه مع جيشها ومرافقته
اثناءها
القرار الذي ايدته 13 دوله امتنعت عن
التصويت عليه روسيا والصين التي اعرب
مندوبها عن اسفه لما سماه تجاهل القرار
لشواغل الدوله المعنيه اي لبنان
ورغم تاكيد القرار ان قوات اليونيفال لا
تحتاج الى تصريح او الى ابن مسبق للقيام
بالمهام المنوطه بها فانه اضاف عباره تنص
على مواصله تنسيق اليونيفيل مع الحكومه
اللبنانيه
كما حتى القرار الذي اسفت مندوبه لبنان
ايضا لعدم استجابته لجميع شواغل لبنان حتى
اسرائيل على التعجيل بانسحاب جيشها من
شمال الغجر والمنطقه المجاوره شمال الخط
الازرق
[موسيقى]
لمناقشتي هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت
قاسم قصير الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
كما ينضم الينا من لندن مهند الحاج علي
الباحث في مركز كارنيجي للشرق الاوسط ومن
انتاريو ينضم الينا اندرو سابلير عضو مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي سابقا اهلا وسهلا
بكم جميعا الى هذه الحلقه ودعونا نبدا مع
بيروت من بيروت مع قاسم الاستاذ قاسم قصير
حول تقييم الجهود كيف تقيم جهود لبنان
المبذوله على طول هذه الفتره
لاقناع مجلس الامن بموقفه
مساء الخير لك ولضيوفك الكرام والمشاهدين
طبعا لبنان سعى في الايام الماضيه من اجل
تغيير بعض نصوص قرار مجلس الامن والتاكيد
على ضروره التنسيق بين القوات الطوارئ
الدوليه والجيش اللبناني قبل القيام باي
مهمه لكن يبدو ان هناك ضغوط امريكيه
واسرائيليه وحتى للاسف بعض الدول العربيه
من اجل عدم تغيير قرار مجلس الامن السابق
او عدم ادخال اي تعديل عليه مما ادى الى
امتناع الصين وروسيا عن التصويت وتحفظ
لبنان رغم ان الرئيس نجيب ميقاتي حسب اخر
المعلومات رحب بقرار التشغيل لان الحراج
يعني هذا الترحيب هو نوع من موقف مبدئي
اولي بضروره استمرار دور قوات الطوارئ
الدوليه لان لبنان لا يزال يعتبر ان وجود
قوات طوارئ الدوليه ضروره من اجل الحفاظ
على الاستقرار لكن انا براي هذا ليست
بالقرار ان هذه القوات قدمت شيئا ما
ملموسا على الارض وهي التي يقال انها لم
تفعل اي شيء خصوصا بين سنه 2006 الى 2022
يعني يصرف سنويا عليها 800 مليون دولار
ولا تقدم اي شيء على الارض هل هذا تقييم
صحيح
ليس صحيحا يعني على الاقل خلال سنوات
الماضيه ساهمت قوات طوارئ الدوليه بتخفيف
التوتر الذي يحصل خصوصا عندما قيام القوات
الاسرائيليه باعتداءات على الاراضي
اللبنانيه او حصول خطف لمزارعين او تطورات
ميدانيه قوات طوارئ لعبه دوره انا براي
اضافه للجيش اللبناني بمنع حصول انتهاكات
من قبل قوات الاسرائيليه للمناطق عديده من
الحدود اللبنانيه سواء بالبر او البحر كما
ان قوات طوارئ لعبت دورا مهما برعايه
الاتفاق الذي حصل بين لبنان والكائن
الصهيوني بشان ترسيم البحري وهي التي
احتضنت يعني متابعه هذا الملف ويمكن ان
يكون لها دور في استكمال معالجه الخروقات
الاسرائيليه على الحدود والتي الان هناك
معلومات ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ستتابع هذا الملف بالمرحله من انجاز ضروري
كل ما ذكرته من انجازات لليونيفل على طول
هذه الفتره كان بالتنسيق مع الجيش
اللبناني والحكمه اللبناني وهنا دعني
انتقل الى اونتاريو واندرو اذا امريكا
لماذا وقفت ضد جهود لبنان في تعديل القرار
اعتقد ان هناك عده اسباب هناك قلق حقيقي
ازاء نشاطات حزب الله على طول الحدود مع
اسرائيل والتي كانت واضحه للعيان تماما
وجاءت بعد الاتفاق على ترسيم الحدود
البحريه والتي قد كان من شانه ان تؤدي الى
مزيد من التعايش السلمي بين لبنان
واسرائيل وخاصه حزب الله لكن هناك قلق
ازاء ذلك كما ان هناك قلق ازاءه ما تريد
الوقت المتحده
من
ما تريد بانه يجب ان لا يكون هناك اخطار
لسلطات لبنانيه لكي يتم نشر الدوريات بشكل
سريع وهناك ايضا بواعظ قلق حول
التوتر بين حزب الله وال جيش اللبناني هذه
ليست جديده لكنها
تفاقمت بسبب النقاشات لهذا السبب الولايات
المتحده انحازت الى الموقف الفرنسي على
وجه الحدود الحاج علي انت كيف ترى جهد
لبنان على هذا الصعيد وهل فجاه كترحيب
ربما نجيب ميقاتي بهذا القرار
مرحبا وتحيه لك المشاهدين والضيوف الكرام
ترحيب نقاطي يعني ياتي ضمن سياق طبيعي
يعني الدوله اللبنانيه دوما ترغب في تخفيف
التوتر على الحدود اللبنانيه ومعالجه ذيول
الصراع الحاصل جنوبا وتحديدا هذه الفتره
يعني اليوم تضاعفت
تضاعفت اهميه هذه القوه نتيجه ارتفاع
التوتر على الحدود الجنوبيه وحصول بضعه
مناوشات لها علاقه بالفصائل الفلسطينيه
ونشاطها المستجد في الجنوب اللبناني
واعتقد بان هذا التطور الجديد جنوبا يجعل
مهمه اليونيفر الاكثر اهميه مما كانت
سابقا لذلك يعني يرحب وطبعا هناك قلق عام
على الساحه السياسيه اللبنانيه من من عدم
التجديد لنقل واستمرار دورها بالمرحله
المقبله
هل هذا الترحيب يعني على خلفيه ان ربما
التعديل يخدم ربما حزب الله لانه في
النهايه التنسيق مع الجيش اللبناني يعني
ان حزب الله سيصله الامر ويقوم بمنع اي
قرار اي شيء يعرقل مهمه القوات الدوليه
ربما من خلال تحريك المواطنين لعرقله عمل
القوات هل هكذا يمكن ان يفهم الامر
صحيح هو تحسن عما كان قائما العام الماضي
وبالتالي هو يخدم رغبه حزب الله في هذا
المجال لكن طبعا لا يلبيها بالكامل بنهايه
المطاف انا كما قال الامين العام لحزب
الله حسن نصر الله قبل قبل ايام هذا الحبر
على ورق في نهايه المطاف معها ما يهم هو
ان
القوى قوى الواقعه على الارض هي التي تقرر
كيف تتحرك قوات حصل العام الماضي حادث ادى
الى مقتل جندي ايرلندي في ديسمبر الماضي
وكان واضحا بان هناك رغبه في تنصيق
دوري
ودائم مع الجيش اللبناني
يكون التنظيم على درايه بما يحصل وتحركات
والا سيحصل ما حصل العام الماضي لذلك فان
تحديد مهمه ليونيل حصلت على الواقع على
ارض الواقع بغض النظر عن ماهيه القرارات
والتعديلات والنصوص الموجوده اليوميه طيب
هذه يطرح سؤال قاسم قصير عن خيارات بيروت
وقد اصبح الان القرار امرا واقعا
يعني ليس هناك خيار الا التعامل مع قوات
طوارئ الدوليه وانا برايي نحن بحاجه الى
مزيد من التنسيق والتعاون بين الجيش
اللبناني وقوات طوارئ في هذه المرحله
الدقيقه في ظل بروز توترات على الحدود
وهذا ليس فقط ناتج كما قال الزميل استاذ
مهند الحاج علي عن موضوع الفلسطيني ناتج
عن قيام اسرائيل بالفتره الماضيه بالعديد
من انتهاكات لاراضي اللبنانيه سواء في
منطقه ما يسمى قريه الغجر وتسمى اليوم
اخراج بلده الماري او في منطقه تلالي
وحصلنا خلال فحص خلال الفتره الماضيه
محاولات يعني حتى ردم احد المواطنين
اللبنانيين من قبل جرافه اسرائيليه
بالتراب وتدخلت قوات طوارئ الدوليه لمنع
ذلك ولمنع استمرار انتهاك اسرائيل للاراضي
اللبنانيه انا برايي نحن بحاجه ميدانيه
وفعليه لمزيد من التنسيق بين قوات الطوارئ
والحكومه اللبنانيه وكذلك حتى يعني بغض
النظر عن اي موقف حتى مع حزب الله حزب
الله هو قوه حقيقيه موجوده على الارض
وتعرف قوات طوارئ الدوليه انه اي مواجهه
مع حزب الله او مع اهالي الجنوب ستكون عكس
بشكل سلبي ولكن
يعني قصدي انا يعني القرار يعني هلا
المضمون القرار النهائي انا لم اقراه لكن
عدم التنسيق مع الجيش هو ينعكس سلبا قوات
طوارئ مزيد من التنسيق يخدم قوات طوارئ
اذا كانت تريد الحفاظ على الاستقرار
والامل اما الذهاب
مع حزب الله انا برايي انا تابعت خلال
السنه الماضيه يعني علاقات قوات طوارئ مع
حزب الله ومع القيادات اللبنانيه وحتى
الحادث الذي جرى خارج منطقه قوى الطوارئ
التي تحدث عنه زميل مهند الحاج علي لم
يحصل في منطقه قوات طوارئ او في منطقه
عملها حصل خارج المنطقه وبعد هذا الحادث
زاد التنسيق والتعاون بين قوات الطوارئ
وبين حزب الله على المستوى العلاقات
والمتابعه قوات طوارئ تدرك ان حزب الله هو
قوه حقيقيه في الجنوب وينبغي متابعه
التواصل معه سواء من قبل الحكومه
اللبنانيه او مباشره ولا مجال يعني اذا
امان الامريكيون موجودين في المجلس الامن
لكن على الارض قوات طوارئ موجوده على
الارض الفرنسيون موجودون الارض وهم يدركون
ان عدم التنسيق الجيش
لاي شيء
يعني يا عم تم معالجه كل الاشكالات التي
حصلت في السنه الماضيه وانا تقديري اليوم
ينبغي المزيد من الحذر والانتباه في دور
قوه الطوارئ وان لا تتعدى حدود الحفاظ على
استقرار اما اذا ارادت ان تتحول الى كما
عبر بعض القيادات اللبنانيه الى كاميرا
لمصلحه الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا ليس لمصلحه
قوه طوارئ الدوليه
نريد ان نفهم اكثر الموقف الامريكي لماذا
لم ياخذ في الاعتبار
التعقيدات التي يتسبب في هذا القرار
بالنسبه لي لبنان
اعتقد ان الامر في النهايه عاد الى
الانتهاكات التي
حصلت والتي تحدث عنها الزملاء وكان هناك
ايضا قلق من جانب اسرائيل عبرت عنه
الولايات المتحده حول مكان يتم في مناطق
الحدود وايضا بواعث القلق المتعلقه
بالعلاقه بين حزب الله والجيش اللبناني
طبعا هذه كلها ليست جديده
لكنها من الامور التي بدات تثير المزيد من
القلق في واشنطن اليوم نسير في هذا
الاتجاه نامل فان يكون هناك حل تناسلي
وهذا هو الفرق بين الموقف الامريكي
والموقف الفرنسي على سبيل ليس في ذلك
تحريف لمهمه هذه القوات هنا اعود الى
مقالتهم مندوبه
لبنان قالت ان قوه الموجوده بطلب من لبنان
يعني هي اصلا موجوده لي حفظ السلام وليس
لفرض السلام
افهم ما تقصدين من كلامك اعتقد ان هناك
تغيرات تحصل
وفي البيئه الامنيه بشكل عام في المناطق
الحدوديه لهذا السبب كان من الطبيعي ان
يدور مثل هذا الجدل والنقاش لكن علينا ان
نرى اولا حزب الله طبعا موجود في جنوب
لبنان
وهناك توتراته مع اسرائيل التي ليست هي
جديده بحد ذاتها لكن لنرى اي حال تنازلي
ممكن ان يتم التوصل لقد نرى ذلك اليوم او
قريبا اشرت الى التوتر مع اسرائيل وهنا
نشير الى ان تمديد مهمه بعثه ياتي على
خلفيه توتر بالفعل على حدود بين لبنان
اسرائيل استدعى بحسب موقع اكس اكس
الاخباري تدخل اداره بايدن من اجل احتوائه
الموقع اكد ان اجتماعا عقد في نيويورك
لهذا الغرض ضم منسقه شؤون الشرق الاوسط في
البيت الابيض وايضا مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي مرمره لف مع وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يواف جالنت والتي والذي اتهم
ايران عقب اجتماعه بالامين العام للامم
المتحده بالسعي لدفع الامور الى الانفجار
على الحدود مع لبنان تطورات تاتي بالتزامن
مع تاكيد واشنطن انها تبحث امكانيه ترسيم
الحدود المتنازع عليها بين لبنان واسرائيل
او اليك مهند الحاج قاسم عفوا
نبحث في التداعيات
المحتمله لهذا القرار في ظل هذا التوتر
الذي اشرنا اليه نبدا بالتوتر على الحدود
مع اسرائيل ما تد اعيات الممكنه برايك او
المحتمله
السؤال
الاستاذ مهند السؤال لك يعني انا تقدير
اليوم رغم التوترات الحاصله هناك مصلحه
امريكيه وحتى مصلحه ايرانيه بالحفاظ على
استقرار خصوصا مع بدء الحفر للبحث عن
الغاز والنفط في المياه اللبنانيه بناء
الاتفاق الذي حصل طبعا اسرائيل هي التي
تحاول توتير الاجواء اولا من خلال ضم قريه
الغجر ثانيا من خلال اقامه بعض المنشات في
مناطق اللبنانيه مثل تلال كفرشوبا
الامريكيون حسب معلوماتي سعوا في الايام
الماضيه ومن خلال التواصل حتى مع شخصيات
لبنانيه للوصول الى حلول من اجل تخفيف
التوتر طبعا المطلب الامريكي كان ازاله
الخيم التي اقامها حزب الله في منطقه تلاك
فرشوبه لكن بالمقابل هناك مطلب لبناني
بازاله التعدد الاسرائيلي على قريه الغجر
الان الاسرائيليون لم يستجيبوا حتى انا
لهذا المطلب لانهم عمدوا الى ضم قريه
الغجر لكن لا يوجد حاليا رغم كل خطاب
التوتر لا يوجد مصلحه لاحد بالذهاب الى
حرب في المنطقه لان هذه الحرب يعني ستؤدي
الى مواجهات شامله في كل منطقه هذا ليس
لمصلحه امريكا ولا لمصلحه ايران ولا
لمصلحه لبنان من هنا انا برايي المساء
اليوم تتركز على الحفاظ على الاستقرار
وعدم تحويل التوترات الموضعيه الى مواجهه
شامله
مع ادراك واشنطن حساسيه هذا الوضع والتوتر
على الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل الا يعقد
هذا برايك ربما مهمه
واشنطن في التوصل في التوسط عفوا هي رسم
الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل لترسيم الحدود
يؤدي الى ذلك وهناك قلق من ان الايرانيين
يحثون ويشجعون حزب الله على نصب هذه الخيم
في قريه الغجر وما حدث في تلك الغرب
القريه اثار الانتباه حول هذا الموضوع
وتجدد
او تجديد ولايه اليونيفال يساعد على حفظ
السلام بين البلدين وتسليط الضوء على هذه
القضاء لكن حقيقه ما يحفظ السلام هو
الشعور لدى كل من حزب الله واسرائيل بان
ايا منهما اذا ما وقع صدام سيتعرض للدمار
لهذا السبب الولايات المتحده
تفاجات بال
هذه الخيم لانهم كانوا يتوقعون ان بعد
اتفاق ترسيم الحدود وكان هناك شعور بان
مثل هذا الاتفاق قد يؤدي الى فتره من
التعايش وتقليل التوتر على الحدود بين
اسرائيل ولبنان مهند حاج علي انت كيف ترى
التداعيات اقليميا لهذا القرار خصوصا فيما
في ظل ما اشرنا اليه من توتر
على الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل وايضا توتر
يتعلق بتعقيدات الملف النوويه الايراني
والعلاقه بين ايران واسرائيل
طبعا لبنان تحول خلال سنوات الماضيه الى
صندوق رسائل يعني هناك قابليه اكثر لحصول
نزاع وتوترات على على الحدود الجنوبيه مما
كان عليه الامر قبل مثلا ثلاث سنوات او
اربع سنوات وهذا نتيجه طبعا اولا نشاط
المسلح الفلسطيني على على الاراضي
اللبنانيه وثانيا طبعا
التوتر الايراني
الخليجي والتوتر الايراني الامريكي الذي
ينعكس بشكل ما على الملف على الوضع الامني
اللبناني عموما
واذا اضفنا الى هذين
التعقيدين الاقليميين تعقيد اخر وهو ما
يحصل على الاراضي الفلسطينيه نفسها هناك
عمليات مقاومه
فلسطينيين في في الضفه الغربيه وايضا
عمليات اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع غزه حين تحصل
اعتداءات اسرائيليه وهذا ينعكس على على
الجنوب اللبناني بشكل اوتوماتيكي هذه
الايام يعني حين تحتدم المواجهات في
الداخل الفلسطيني نرى ان هناك تحركا من
جنوب لبنان باتجاه
الشمالي
الشمال اسرائيل وهذا ينعكس على ايضا قدره
الدوله اللبنانيه على التعامل مع هذا
الواقع في ظل هذا الانهيار المتمادي
اقتصاديا وماليا هناك قلق رسمي لبناني من
حصول مثل هذا التوتر والتصعيد
واعتقد بان عوامل الانفجار باتت اكثر
بكثير مما كانت عليه في السابق ولذلك
التجديد لينوفل في هذه المرحله الدقيقه
يكتسي اهميه اكبر من من الصبا
[موسيقى]
الوقت شكرا لك مهند الحاج علي الباحث في
مركز كارنيجي للشرق للابحاث للسلام في
الشرق الاوسط
ونشكر ضيفنا من بيروت قاسم قصير الكاتب
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي ومن انتاريو
اندرويد سابلير عضو مجلس الامن القوميه
الامريكي سابقا
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]